[Music]
this July 4th revisit the movie that
made pulling up American landmarks cool
until 9/11 but now 12 years later it's
apparently cool again Independence Day
fulfilled that answered whether we're
alone in the universe
by stealing from all the other films
that answered whether we're alone in the
universe
featuring the premise from War of the
Worlds the aliens from alien the
spaceships from V the dogfights from
Star Wars the Statue of Liberty from
Planet of the Apes and the Jeff Goldblum
from Jurassic Park must know faster must
go faster to battle against an alien
threat humanity's last hope is this
ragtag group of survivors fighter pilot
Steven Hiller of Fresh Prince of the air
who says cool things even when there's
no one around to hear them David
Levinson a Jeff Goldblum like satellite
engineer listen to this get out of town
yes yes not special
[Applause]
we all take them take them out take them
down and do your threw your stuff
and Thomas Whitmore the best movie
president ever no cop who channels
William Shatner you'll see if you're as
smart as we all hope you are his
thoughts the doctors gonna be just fine
prepare to stand up and cheer as they
defeat an advanced alien race with a
sheet Morse code punchy
Roth and Apple PowerBook 5300 and cousin
Eddie travel back to a time when summer
blockbusters were fun and uplifting and
I promise your fireworks not dark and
nobody in a movie that will trigger more
90s nostalgia than the front page of
BuzzFeed
featuring REM CD ROMs but the hellizac
data the last 24 hours have been really
exciting and Fruitopia witness a film
whose message of global unity means only
america can save the world
it's from the Americans there was no
organized a counter-offensive it's about
bloody time what are they trying to do
and drill an explosive action that
casually murders millions of people but
won't hurt this dog so this Independence
Day prepared to once again relive the
screen watching
[Music]
the sky watching
and the speech watching we will not go
quietly into the night we will not
finish
we're going to live on we're going to
survive today we celebrate our
Independence Day hell yeah
starring Jaden's dad president Lone Star
President Laura Roslin Apple Genius
crazy Dennis Quaid Michael Buble jr. not
Jaden nerdy Fabio
vivica not actually a fox and the best
extra ever Independence Day can someone
explain to me how they've already made
three Chronicles of Riddick movies and
yet I still have to wait until 2015 for
a sequel to this I don't always
subscribe but when i do i subscribe to
screen junkies Soylent Green is people
stupid sexy Flanders wibbly-wobbly
timey-wimey no Mr Bond I expect you to
die you're gonna like the way you look I
guarantee it